The air hummed, a space a few feet off the
ground rippling like a calm lake disturbed
by a stone thrown at its surface.
Not that there was anyone around to see it.
Which, of course, begged the age-old question
that has baffled philosophers, scientists,
and pretty much everyone with a working brain
for centuries.
That being, if an interdimensional fracture
leading to an infinite multiverse of endlessly
recurring realities opens up in a hotel resort
bedroom in Mexico, and nobody is there to
see it, then did it really happen at all?
Well, in this instance, it really did.
With a flash of light, a figure came tumbling
through the wormhole, fizzling out of existence
in one place only to arrive somewhere similar.
Behind him, the purplish tear in the very
fabric of reality sealed itself shut as quickly
and inexplicably as it had opened.
Sitting up, his Hawaiian shirt a disheveled
mess, the man blinked through his blurred
vision.
Eddie Brock was unsure if his headache was
the result of an intense hangover or the process
of being flung between universes, seemingly
at random.
“Are we back?”
a voice in the back of Eddie’s head growled.
“I have no idea, pal,” Eddie replied aloud,
looking around the vacant hotel room, the
last of the daylight fading as the sun set.
“We should eat,” the gravelly voice replied.
“I’m hungry.”
“That’s all you ever think about,” he
replied.
“I don’t even have any money on me.
Besides, don’t you think we should try and
figure out where we are first?”
“Nope!”
In seconds, a dark, gooey substance morphed
over Eddie from head to toe, encasing him
and his clothes.
It formed a body, a towering, hulking monster
with wide, white eyes in the shape of teardrops.
Its mouth was filled with rows of long, razor-sharp
teeth.
The black goo was constantly shifting.
In fact, it was alive; an alien symbiote bonded
with its human host in order to survive.
Together, the symbiote and Eddie were Venom.
Bursting out of the hotel’s balcony as night
rapidly fell, Venom fired organic webs from
his wrists and swung through the city in search
of food.
Agent Hardy hated fieldwork.
He’d imagined working for the SCP Foundation
would be full of action and thrilling espionage
and had enrolled in undercover training, hoping
he’d be sent on missions to stealthily infiltrate
other anomalous organizations like the Church
of the Broken God or Global Occult Coalition.
Instead, he was assigned to deep cover, which
was a Foundation euphemism for ‘stay put
and keep your eyes peeled just in case you
spot something unusual’.
He had been stationed in Mexico City, and
was forced to work a menial job in a tiny
little convenience store to maintain cover;
a waste of his advanced combat and reconnaissance
training, he thought.
Agent Hardy badly wanted more, and found it
personally insulting that the Foundation saw
it fit to waste an asset like him, while he
should have been made part of one of their
Mobile Task Forces.
Only adding to that perceived insult, was
the fact that nothing all that unusual or
even remotely anomalous ever seemed to happen
nearby.
That is, until a seven-foot-tall, five-hundred-pound
oily black monster came barrelling into the
convenience store, barged its way over to
the confectionary aisle, and started shoveling
fistfuls of chocolate into its mouth.
All before dashing back out and swinging away
with as many candy bars as it could carry
in one arm.
“Hardy, if somebody robbed your store, that’s
a job for the local police department,”
the bored-voiced Foundation operator replied
over the radio as Agent Hardy contacted command.
“No, not just somebody, something!”
Hardy yelled while the store’s customers
ran screaming from the scene.
“It’s a goddamn alien.
I saw it with my own eyes.
It’s huge!”
“Hold on, one moment,” the operator replied,
before turning to a colleague, still audible
over the radio; meanwhile, Agent Hardy tapped
his foot impatiently.
“Didn’t we get a blip near there…
When?
I don’t know the exact time, about an hour
ago tops.
Any read on what it was?
Interdimensional disturbance?
Could be connected.”
“Look, how do you want me to proceed?”
Hardy barked.
“Uh, follow at a distance Agent Hardy,”
the operator replied.
“Be advised do not engage with the creature
under any circumstances.
It could be carrying any number of unknown
pathogens or diseases we don’t have cures
for, if it is from another universe.
Strictly observation only.
Mobile Task Force Null-6 is inbound to contain
your… alien.”
Agent Hardy turned and dashed out of the store,
sprinting down the street.
A little way in the distance, Venom had been
swinging from buildings.
They were singing I Got You Under My Skin
to themselves without a care in the world,
before landing on a rooftop and starting to
ravenously munch on their remaining chocolate
bars.
“Ahhh, delicious,” Venom growled after
finishing their feast.
“So, when are we gonna work on getting back
home?”
Eddie asked, half of the symbiote’s protective
‘mask’ retracting to show him underneath.
“This might be our home!”
Venom retorted.
“This planet looks the same in every universe.”
“Look, I really think we ought to prioritize
getting out of here!”
the human half of them argued.
“That should be our priority, not feeding
you!”
“Eddie, we’ve been over this, I need phenethylamine
to live, and since you get all indignant at
me for eating brains, we have to get it from
a more socially acceptable source,” the
alien creature replied.
“Unless…”
“Unless what?”
Brock asked.
“Unless you wanna go find some bad guys’
brains to eat?”
the symbiote queried.
“Hey, you!”
someone yelled.
“Hold it right there!”
As if on cue, the sounds of weapons being
locked and loaded interrupted their conversation.
In the time since Agent Hardy had called it
in, The Foundation’s Mobile Task Force had
arrived on the rooftop.
Hardy was with them, hanging back and letting
the other operatives move in to apprehend
the alien.
Drawing themselves to their full height, Venom
turned to face the approaching squad of armed
soldiers, their face returning to its full,
sharp-toothed form.
“Bad guys?”
Venom growled, grinning widely.
“Guys with guns pointed at us, I’m gonna
guess probably bad guys,” Eddie answered,
before noticing the logo’s emblazoned on
the MTFs uniforms.
“Hold up, ‘SCP Foundation’?
Like the Life Foundation?”
“Who cares?”
Venom declared.
“They’re dinner!”
“Open fire!”
the MTF commander yelled, before being suddenly
silenced – Venom had grabbed him and was
beginning to close his jaws around his head.
The remaining members of the task force followed
their squad leader’s final command and pulled
their triggers.
The rooftop erupted into a hail of gunfire,
bullets impacting with Venom’s oily form
but causing no damage, bouncing off their
outer, gelatinous skin.
They lunged at another of the MTF troopers,
wrenching the man’s weapon from his hands
and hurling it away, before grabbing him by
his ankle.
With incredible strength, Venom flung the
operative around in the air as if he was a
ragdoll, swinging him into the other troops,
sending them flying.
Hanging back from the fight, Agent Hardy was
trying to observe the creature’s attack
patterns; although it seemed to just be chaotically
flinging an MTF operative around as a weapon
rather than deploying any form of actual technique.
He wanted to spot an opening, a weakness,
anything that could take down this hulking
alien monster, but not one was presenting
itself.
That is, until Venom finished swinging that
helpless Foundation soldier around and threw
the man over their shoulder.
The MTF troop dropped limply down to street
level, landing on a parked car with a loud
crash and the sound of glass shattering, which
was followed by the wailing of the car’s
emergency alarm.
The screeching noise seemingly caused Venom
to reel from their fight with the MTF, roaring
and gripping their head to drown out the alarm.
“Sound,” Hardy muttered to himself.
“Its weakness is sound.”
Instantly, he turned to one of the other MTF
soldiers and dashed towards him, while Venom
was lashing out in an enraged state.
The strands of the symbiote were recoiling,
exposing Eddie contained beneath.
Agent Hardy grabbed the nearest Foundation
operative and violently struck him in the
face, taking advantage of the trooper’s
shock to pull his weapon out of his hands
and push him towards the edge of the rooftop.
He delivered another blow, feeling his fellow
Foundation agent’s nose cracking against
his fist as he took out all his frustrations
with his undercover posting.
The task force operative could barely believe
what was happening, too dumbfounded and in
too much pain to protest.
Even when he did weakly lift his arms to defend
his face, Agent Hardy effortlessly swatted
them away and smashed his forehead into the
other agent’s face, dazing him as he dragged
him right up to the ledge.
There was nothing between the captive soldier,
just a sheer, multi-story drop down to street
level.
Lining him up, Agent Hardy shoved the other
man off the roof, so he landed on a second
car.
Its alarm started blaring, the horn too as
the fallen agent’s body went through the
windshield, adding even more loud noises to
the mix.
Such a deafening combination of loud sounds
caused Venom to keel over, roaring in pain
as the symbiote’s main weakness pierced
it.
If the noise continued for too long, it would
force Eddie and his alien accomplice to separate,
and so the slimy form defensively retreated
into its host, leaving him alone.
Wearing a triumphant, smug look on his face,
Agent Hardy marched over to the human being
that was left.
The alien form was gone, for now, meaning
he could just raise his stolen weapon and
strike Eddie hard in the face, knocking him
out, ready for the Foundation to take him
– and the symbiote – in for examination.
After hours of torture, that Agent Hardy had
volunteered to conduct personally, the Foundation
had learned that a sustained barrage of high-frequency
soundwaves could be used to forcibly separate
the gelatinous alien life form from its host.
Once they had been parted, Eddie Brock didn’t
need much more containment than any other
average human; while the symbiote could be
placed in a glass tank for Foundation researchers
to take a closer look at.
“The creature seems to possess a consciousness,
its own mobility; it's an entirely separate
entity from Mr. Brock,” one of the researchers
commented, observing a sample of the symbiote
that they had managed to slice off the larger
whole, and was now slithering its way around
a smaller, transparent containment cube.
“That’s pretty obvious, Poindexter,”
Agent Hardy retorted impatiently.
“Why don’t you give me something useful?”
“W-well,” the researcher stammered, intimidated
by the imposing field operative.
“It appears to be rapidly deteriorating.”
“That thing is dying?”
Hardy asked.
“It seems so.
We’ve been able to access some sort of hive
mind that it shares with the rest of its kind.
Apparently, these…” he checked his notes.
“Klyntar are able to share knowledge across
multiple realities.
But they need to remain bonded to a host in
order to survive, on their own their lifespans
are much shorter,” the researcher added.
“But it seems that, once they have, they
increase the host’s strength, replicate
their own mass, even use more of itself to
create weapons.”
“Weapons?”
the Agent echoed.
“Yes, yes.
Anything, it seems some of these symbiotes
could even create copies of existing weaponry,
that would act as extensions of itself, fully
useable by the host.”
“Thank you, Doc.
That info should come in pretty handy…”
Agent Hardy replied.
“I b-beg your pardon, Agent?”
the researcher asked, before Agent Hardy’s
hand gripping his throat silenced him.
Elsewhere in the facility, Eddie Brock was
yelling, demanding to be let free.
His only thought was getting back to Venom,
aware that his symbiote partner would wither
and die if they remained apart for too long.
Thanks to their bond, he knew Venom was thinking
the same at this precise moment, and it only
spurred him on to try and pull himself free.
He was handcuffed to a chair, barely able
to move.
Normally, the pair of them could get out of
a jam like this with no trouble; after all,
things were always easier when they were together.
“I got you!”
Eddie started to sing, loudly and tunelessly.
“Under my skin!”
“Quiet!”
snapped a Foundation security officer who
stood nearby.
“I got you,” he ignored the guard and
continued, making his voice even louder.
“Deep in the heart of me!
So deep in my heart that you’re really a
part of me!
I got you…”
“I said, quiet!”
the officer barked, marching over to Eddie,
baton raised threateningly.
With a sudden, unrelenting strike, he kicked
the guard in the stomach with all the force
he could manage.
Winded, the officer crumpled, dropping to
the floor as he gasped for air.
Not letting up, Eddie kicked again, this time
his boot connected with the man’s jaw and
knocked him out.
It wouldn’t last forever though; using his
legs, and with a great deal of difficulty
Eddie tried to lift the handcuff keys from
the officer’s belt.
He hardly possessed perfect coordination,
meaning it required a lot of trial and error,
but knowing Venom needed him made him all
the more determined to try again and again.
Until, finally, Eddie pulled the keys up with
his boots, lifted his legs, so they slid down,
and caught them in his cuffed hand.
Freeing himself, he left the unconscious security
guard cuffed in his place, before making his
way through the facility as quickly and quietly
as he could.
It didn’t matter that he had never been
there before, he could sense Venom anywhere;
even though they were apart, all he had to
do was follow the pull to where it was being
held.
However, he could’ve done with his symbiote
partner’s protection when he arrived in
the lab.
Something tore through Eddie’s shoulder,
embedding itself in his flesh.
Screaming with pain, he lifted a hand to the
bleeding wound, only to feel a second shot
strike him in the gut.
He could feel the projectile in his hand;
gritting his teeth, he pulled it out.
It was a tooth, blood-soaked, and fired with
the force of a bullet.
It was then that Eddie looked up and saw where
from.
Towering over him, Agent Hardy looked almost
unrecognizable.
He had bonded with the sample cut off the
symbiote, and it had encased his body in a
suit all of his own.
His had black, segmented plates, like armor,
although with the same gelatinous, oily appearance
as Venom.
In his hands was what looked like a submachine
gun, but was, in actuality, something special
the agent had requisitioned from the Foundation’s
anomalous armory.
It was SCP-127, a weapon that – like the
symbiote – was also an organic, living being,
capable of firing human-like teeth in the
place of bullets.
To make matters worse, the shred of symbiote
Hardy wore had cloned its own versions of
SCP-127, their handles extending into long,
black tendrils that protruded from the agent’s
back.
The rest of Venom was still contained in a
tank, frantically slithering against the glass,
trying to free itself and get to Eddie.
If it did, it could heal his injuries and
make itself whole again.
Stomping over to where his wounded victim
lay, Symbiote-infused Hardy pulled Eddie up
from the floor and lifted him off his feet,
making sure he dug his symbiote-coated thumb
into his wounds, making Eddie cry out in pain.
“Gotta be said, Mr. Brock,” Hardy grinned
sadistically.
“I can see why you’d want to be merged
with one of these things.
The strength it gives you is… amazing!
Enough to make anybody take you seriously,
remind them not to underestimate you.
And that’s all from me getting a little
piece, imagine how strong I’ll be when I’m
combined with your little alien friend there.”
“You should know,” Eddie winced.
“Venom’s a little picky about who he hangs
out with.
And trust me, you’re not his type.”
“Oh yeah?”
Agent Hardy roared.
With his symbiote-enhanced strength, he hurled
Eddie across the lab with such force that
he smashed the glass tank, before colliding
with the far wall and landing in a heap.
Eddie was still bleeding heavily from the
teeth he’d been shot with, as Venom tried
– in its weakened state – to slide across
the floor towards him… only for Hardy to
catch it.
He lifted the rest of the dark, gooey symbiote
up and dangled it tauntingly over Eddie as
he lay bleeding out on the floor.
“You’re nothing without this thing attached
to you, Brock,” Hardy jeered.
“In fact, even when you were bonded on that
rooftop, you were easy enough to take down.
Guess even together, you two are nothing.”
“N-no,” Eddie rasped weakly, reaching
his hand up with the last of his fading strength;
as he did, Hardy didn’t notice the symbiote
reaching back to its host.
“Together we’re… we’re a…”
The alien life form gave a surge, and slipped
over Eddie’s hand.
Instantly, his gunshot wounds sealed up and
repaired, just as the dark, slimy form encased
him once more.
Standing up, catching Hardy by surprise, Venom
gripped the Agent by the neck.
“We’re a Lethal Protector, you feel me?”
they growled, grinning and showing off their
sharp rows of teeth.
Venom lifted Agent Hardy up and threw him
hard enough to send him crashing through the
wall, landing a few feet away.
“Glad to have you back,” came Eddie’s
voice.
“Good to be back!”
Venom replied.
“Were you singing our song earlier?”
“Yeah,” Eddie sighed.
“That’s how I escaped.”
Before they could continue their conversation,
Agent Hardy roared at them.
Staggering back to his feet, he began firing
SCP-127 at Venom, the various copies his symbiote
had created unleashing a barrage of toothy
projectiles at them.
They didn’t ricochet off like regular bullets,
in fact they seemed to be strong enough to
shred through Venom’s outer symbiote skin,
until it had a chance to reform.
“Ouch!”
they roared.
“Oh yeah, his guns shoot teeth!”
Eddie warned, slightly too late.
“This guy sucks!”
Venom growled.
“No arguments there,” Eddie replied.
“You got a plan here, partner?”
“I am open to suggestions, Eddie!”
the symbiotic half answered as they retreated
from the gunfire, Hardy charging after them.
The Agent lunged at them, tackling Venom,
pinning them down and delivering a vicious
punch.
The force of it split the symbiote head apart,
revealing Eddie beneath.
“You don’t deserve this much power!”
Agent Hardy yelled, lifting one of his oily
black tooth-firing guns to Eddie’s exposed
face.
Just as he fired, Venom’s ‘mask’ reformed,
in the nick of time to protect its host.
As the tooth impacted their face, both Eddie
and his symbiote partner noticed something.
Hardy’s symbiote seemed to suffer the same
damage, slickly parting and then quickly reforming.
“He’s just wearing a part of you, right,
V?”
Eddie asked.
“When we get hurt, he gets hurt!
We just need to hurt him enough to get them
to separate, and you can get that part of
your body back!”
Venom lifted their head, noticing a button
on the wall of the corridor.
The Foundation had plenty of need for emergency
alarms in case an anomaly broke containment,
and sure enough, there was one labeled ‘Activate
in Case of Emergency’.
Raising one arm, Venom fired a line of organic
web at the button.
The screaming, ringing sound had both Venom
and Agent Hardy writing in agony.
The symbiote began retracting from the Foundation
field agent as the alarm blared.
He weakly tried to crawl towards it, desperate
to switch it off before his suit separated
from him.
A fist sailed through the air and clocked
Hardy square in the jaw: Eddie had landed
a hit.
He’d knocked Hardy over, keeping him down
for long enough so that the portion of the
symbiote that had been removed leaped off
the agent’s body, and quickly crawled its
way back to its original host.
Shutting the alarm off again, Eddie was once
again encased in the form of the Lethal Protector,
and they towered over Agent Hardy, long, slimy
tongue unraveling from their razor-toothed
jaws.
“Just who in the hell do you think you are?”
Hardy spat, enraged.
“We…
are Venom.”
Agent Hardy’s screams echoed through the
halls of the site, then quickly fell silent
with a meaty crunch.
Not long after, Venom noticed that they were
starting to fade from this universe again.
“Uh, Eddie, it’s happening again,” Venom
exclaimed.
“We’d better end up home this time!”
Eddie sighed as they disappeared, leaving
the Foundation to clean up the mess they’d
left behind.
Now go check out “ SCP Elite Mobile Task
Force Explained” and “How to Work at the
SCP Foundation Explained” if, much like
Agent Hardy, you need a crash course in how
a proper SCP Foundation operative should behave!